hey guys it's katie and we are back for
another recipe translation challenge for
jasmine we have taken a recipe put it
through google translate we've gone from
english to french to tagalog to
ukrainian to swahili and many many many
more all the way back to english to give
us a hilariously translated recipe other
youtubers have done stuff similar to
this brandon ferris melinda we were
inspired what what jimmy fallon does
with music lyrics on his show they're
all great please check them out i think
it's time to give jasmine the new recipe
and let her know how much harder i've
made it this time per your guys's
request it's your fault we read the
comments it's me fun before i give you
this there are some changes we've made
today i am going to try my best not to
laugh everyone has requested it look
what you've done you've taken the joy
out of her producing this we put more
stuff out and you will get no hints from
kelly and i except for one each can i
trade yours and have two kelly my kids
are great all right are you ready for
the recipe
coco's dream
what oh also jasmine is not allowed to
read ahead of the recipe so if you guys
write read ahead i've strictly told her
not to i'm not allowed to break the
rules guys you wanted it hard this is
hard all right jasmine are you ready i
guess so let's make coco's dream
insert twinkle sound effect step one
place 14 tablespoons of
step one you're not allowed to do that
you already broke the ruler you're gonna
get flamed by the audience step one
place 14 tablespoons oil and three
quarter cups tablespoon yogurt in a
large bowl with your finger press and
hold the key until it stops beat each
other using a mix
where to begin oh it's really hard
because i can't read forward there is
yogurt butter there's butter there's
butter three quarter cups
of yogurt i think i'm going to combine
butter and yogurt in a bowl press the on
button and mix it until it's
well blended
i think it's butter
all right
but then what's six
a third plus a half
this better be the only math step it
says 14 tablespoons of oil there's no
way it's that simple okay i'm gonna do
14 tablespoons of butter i think we're
making something sweet but i could be
very much wrong coco's dream sounds so
sweet i'm just going to do 3 4 cup of
yogurt do you feel like you've made the
right decision so far no
with your finger
press and hold the key until it stops
like ikea directions i'm gonna mix this
i'm just gonna do it until it's well
combined i hope i got that right step
number two add the three cup bread one
cup sugar and two teaspoons bread and
smooth what add three cup bread i found
bread crumbs i can't say that i think
this is correct
i have found bread sugar sugar i think
bread is flour three cups flour
one cup sugar i'm gonna start with sugar
because i know that well i don't know
but it's the most straightforward all
right one cup sugar i'm so stressed so i
have decided to do three cups of flour
so the tea two teaspoons bread is is
kind of confusing what is this what's
that two teaspoons of baking powder i
wish i had a live audience to clap for
me
i don't know if i'm baking this so now
we do and smooth i'm having a good time
but this is hard okay now i'm kind of
confused the last two words were and
smooth but this is definitely pretty dry
it looks like this usually when i'm
baking if it gets to this and there's
like some sort of solid dough i can
start kneading so i'm going to start
kneading until the dough is smooth maybe
there was no yogurt needed
i'm wondering what cuisine this is
that's like my favorite part while i'm
needing this can i read the next step
put in a plastic oven to cool for 10
minutes that's a juxtaposition right
there i'm going to put it in a plastic
bag
and cool for 10 minutes in the fridge i
love that this time you guys are gonna
comment saying make it easier for
jasmine
i think this is good let's just wrap
this up
let's chill it for 10 minutes next step
place the pan with two letters delivery
in a 350 degree oven what place the pan
with two letters delivery baking sheet
two letters delivery let me just look
around a little bit two to two baking
sheets i decided to do two baking sheets
with parchment paper which is our
letters i'm gonna go preheat the oven to
350. next step divide flour into 15
coins using a knife or a trowel the hell
is a trowel trowel trowel travel oh look
at that it's labeled a trowel
oh i can use a knife i kind of want to
use this i'm going to use this because
why not divide flour into 15 coins i
assume round how was it used in the
trowel it's not bad actually not sure
how even it is but i don't think it's
okay all right 15. i will roll them into
balls what do you imagine coco's dream
looks like coco's dream naturally i'm
thinking coco is very chocolatey dream
what's synonymous with dream clouds coco
clout chocolate clouds chocolate
chocolate puffs pop chocolate puffs i
don't think i got it next step circle
each piece into a small square about
eight inches by four inches
make a right angle well i assume i'm
rolling it out to be eight by four
with right angles eight by four one two
three
four four double that eight eight there
are rollers there it doesn't say how
thin though so is eight by four in just
a square
or a circle well a circle is not a
square an eight by four is a rectangle
circle is roll roll each piece
into a
small square rectangle a thin thin
rectangle place the cherry earthquake on
the long side of the long side round the
flower around the cherries in a bowl
with herbs cherry earthquake there's
strawberries here blueberries and sour
cherry sour could be translated to
earthquake how so tell me take me on
that road sour bitter bitter strong bomb
explosion earthquake i like it
i got it round the flower around the
cherries in a bowl with herbs what herbs
i'm gonna go with sour cherries here i'm
gonna drain them
i think i'm going to line the cherries
on the long side is it just like one
line you know and how how much you know
what i'm going to use a hint oh
who do you want your hit from kelly so
round is what shape oh
oh
oh
i think i am rolling it over the
cherries and there's a log of cherries
on the long side of the long side all
right i do feel a lot better that looks
decent in a bowl with
herbs i have thyme i have mint sage oh
was i supposed to put it inside
i'm gonna do it again with the other one
but with the cherries i'm also gonna
line some mint inside and then roll it
up i have my cherry mint log just gonna
do this 13 more times brb finally rolled
all these out next step add the prepared
pasta roll out the remaining dough and
cover with the spoon what so i think i
am going to roll out the remaining dough
what's the prepared pasta
there is no remaining dough why would
pasta be in this dish i think i got to
use a hint katie you want a hint for moi
i mean you said i couldn't get too
grungy sometimes in recipes it tells you
how to do all of it in one step then the
next step is telling you to repeat it
was that a bad hint
damn it my hint was that i already did
it
step nine if the egg is dry beat the
beaten egg and cook for two minutes
until golden brown egg wash and cook for
two minutes
egg wash
that's what i'm gonna do let's beat that
all right two minutes is not
that long i'm hoping the next step will
be like cooking longer how did you even
find this recipe suggested by you guys
y'all are good next step remove the
wooden cookies to bake from the oven for
15 minutes i'm just gonna ignore the
numbers and i'll take them out when
they're golden brown make frosty make
put the cream and two cups of cane in a
large bowl wash with a handkerchief
until black make frosty make make frosty
make make frosting make frosting cane
sugar cane sugar cream put what cream
there's so much cream sour cream cream
cheese and heavy whipping cream i'm
going with cream cheese i'm choosing
this because if you let me think about
it for any longer i'm gonna put them all
two cups of cane in a large bowl i think
it's sugar i'm just trying to think of
the flavors like if it's super wrong
yeah whatever if it's good yeah you seem
more at peace today i am just getting
back into the groove of failure how do
you feel about failing katie i'm asian i
think you know perfectly well how i feel
about failure unacceptable oh i don't
even know if this is right i didn't read
the next step wash with the handkerchief
until black this feels like strawberry
king king
do i make it black i'm just gonna mix it
first i feel like there's there's no way
it wouldn't want me to mix it together i
have a feeling i was wrong
can i redo my step can i do a little
round i don't know
wrong way fine you have to do it so fast
though
resume i am doing heavy whipping cream
instead of cream cheese wash with a
handkerchief until black
maybe maybe it's
mix
with the mixer
until
thick
okay also i can't let go of the fact
that it says wash with the handkerchief
until black and then there's food
coloring here and i feel like i should
just add some in case
and if it's wrong it's okay
i'm just gonna add a little bit don't
know how i feel about that i think this
is done i'm gonna go check on the
roll-ups i think it's been about i don't
have a watch i've taken these out of the
oven and let them cool it's time to move
on to the next step i have no idea how
i'm doing right now put five pieces
under the pan wash well with a brush
five under a pan five under blow pot
plate five
four from this step it's telling me that
we are in assembly mode i assume this
will be the base since it's only five
and we have 15 of them i am just putting
five pieces on top let's move on to the
next step oh wash well with the brush
what would i wash with wait there's
frosting here frosting sounds pretty
good
oh oh my frosting maybe i guess i'll do
frosting
here goes
i'm freaking out i'm gonna keep it under
control add four more at the top and
place in the middle of everything below
eat a thin layer of sugar so what i'm
gonna do maybe this this way opposite
way mom don't watch this episode eat a
thin layer of sugar maybe just another
layer of frosting powdered sugar i will
just do more of this repeat with other
cookies to create a pyramidal image i'm
thinking
like this oh wait no if i repeat it's
not going to be a pyramid though oh i
i understand i shouldn't have switched
directions so i added three this time
and i have three left this black
frosting is so ugly i think it's wrong
but i kind of it kind of looks like a
campfire step 15 bread the rest of the
frost on the outside refrigerate the
remaining ice cubes for two to four okay
i guess i spread the remaining frosting
on the outside so good it sounds good no
i appreciate the hype though i'm
actually really horrified refrigerate
the remaining ice cubes for two to four
frosting refrigerate refrigerate the
frosting this fridge this i i want to
say this is the ice cube
[Music]
i don't even know if we're going to use
those again so i'm going to do this
let's do
24 hours i'm not staying here 24 hours
yet let's just put it in the fridge to
chill all right i have chilled this baby
for about 20 minutes and now we are on
our last step sprinkle crushed chocolate
on the scalp before serving crushed
chocolate scallop head top sprinkled
crushed chocolate out here could be
powdered sugar
well there's some chocolate over here i
think it's probably gonna be this maybe
i can do chocolate shavings on top uh i
think i'm gonna do chocolate shavings
scalp chocolate shavings kind of like
dandruff oh beautiful oh if coco's dream
is chocolate we gotta give coco a lot of
cocoa tada
what do you think i'm so confused but
i'm done it's time to see the real one
and find out what this is called for
real
are you ready to see it i'm a little
nervous i feel like this one might be
the biggest miss yet but whatever
happens i will be proud close your eyes
it's coming in hot open your eyes it's
coming in hot open your eyes
oh my gosh it's so cute you want to know
the name kushma lui gaguta which
translates to gaguta's hat the name
comes from a moldovan folk tale about a
boy shepherd who fits an entire village
under his large traditional hat to
shield from the brutal winter weather oh
that's so cute
well i messed up a lot why don't we give
yours a cut
cheers
the mint is really bad cheers
that's a lot better than mine where did
i go wrong are there herbs in there
no herbs
i feel pretty good i think i was closer
than i thought in terms of the visuals
but the taste yeah the mint really
changed it and i love that there's a
story behind this dish maybe next time
is your turn katie no no never
[Laughter]
this is a lot of fun if you guys want to
see your recipe featured next time make
sure to dm katie at old lady katie we'll
see you guys next time you did great you
did really well no longer coco's dream
coco's nightmare
you